to get the most out of what's said to be
one of the biggest most unmissable
blockbusters of the summer and possibly
the year we've rounded up the tidbits
and plot details you'll want to brush up
on here's everything you need to know
before you see fast and furious presents
Hobbes and Shaw when the character is
first introduced in Fast Five Johnson's
agent Luke Hobbs is a straight-laced
do-gooder in the Diplomatic Security
Service as a result he spends the
majority of that movie tracking down Vin
Diesel's Dominic Toretto in a bid to
stop dominus crew from pulling off the
most outlandish heist Ryo has ever seen
but it's not long before Hobbs
grudgingly sees the good in the game and
decides to work with them the vaults of
money their high steam belongs to drug
lord Fernan Reyes who is so peeved about
his profits getting plundered that he
kills Hobbes's entire team and attempts
to frame Toretto and his gang for the
hit but Hobbs is smarter than the
average beefcake and collaborates with
the fast crew to get even with Reyes
Fast Five marked the beginning of a
fruitful relationship between Hobbs and
Toretto's gang with Hobbs growing to
understand the complicated gray area
between being a good guy and a bad guy
here's where the soap-opera leanings of
The Fast and Furious franchise really
start going into overdrive when Hobbs
returns in Fast & Furious 6 he teams up
with the gang again to take down
terrorists oh and sha sha ends up in a
coma after his battle with the fast
family but there's also a twist ending
which introduces Jason Statham as Owens
brother Deckard Shaw a post-credits
scene reveals that he was behind team
member Hans death in the Fast and
Furious Tokyo Drift
although Tokyo Drift is the third film
of the franchise it takes place between
the events of Fast & Furious 6 and
Furious 7 Deckard continues as the
baddie in Furious 7
but he's grudgingly forced to make nice
with the fast gang to get even with the
big bad and fate of the Furious still by
the end of the film Shaw is pretty clear
about the fact that none of his baby
saving action scenes made him a willing
member of Toretto's family come believe
you wanna see my mother
that makes him the perfect foil for
Hobbs one of the biggest reasons Hobbs
and Shaw have such an entertaining
dynamic is that they have complementary
character arcs within the series while
Hobbs has realized that he sometimes has
to break a few laws and collaborate with
criminals to save the day
Shaw has discovered that sometimes he
needs to help of good guys to carry out
his dirty deeds their conflicting sets
of morals and goals have given them one
of the most fascinating and hilarious
relationships in the franchise as
highlighted by the Prison Break scene
from the fate of the Furious these two
rivals are often forced to fight
alongside one another while also
fighting against each other speaking to
IGN
director David leach has copped to the
fact that Hobson Shaw was influenced by
the buddy cop films he grew up loving
there's his buddy movies from the 80s
and 90s like Lethal Weapon or 48 hours
that really speak to me and as a
filmmaker if you've even caught just
five minutes of a fast and furious movie
then you already know just how important
family is to the franchise I don't have
friends I got family not only is it
Toretto's favorite word and motive for
committing crimes but those family
values also provide the backbone for
much of the franchise's major plots
Hobbes and Shaw looks to be extending
these values from the franchise to the
spin-off - not only is Fast and Furious
superfan Helen Mirren returning to play
Shaw's rough-and-ready mother but his
sister played by Vanessa Kirby is also
showing up as a main character patty
Shaw an mi5 agent looks to be bringing
some serious trouble in Hobbs in Shaw's
direction she'll be appealing to Shaw's
loyalty to family and Hobbes's loyalty
to saving the world and taking down
Idris Elba's villainous Brixton but it
isn't just Shaw's brood that'll be a
major part of the movie though we
haven't seen much of Hobbes's family in
the franchise so far it looks as though
Hobbs and Shaw will be introducing
audiences to Hobbes's full Samoan family
the most recent trailer for the movie
teases a massive set piece involving
Hobbes's family who looked like they'll
be putting their traditional fighting
skills to good use in helping their
brother defeat Brixton's endless squad
of bad guys interestingly the family
connection doesn't end there Johnson's
cousin WWE wrestler Roman reigns will be
swinging a sledgehammer of family
justice as Hobbs's brother speaking
Empire leech has teased great things for
the battle
particularly for fans of a good
old-fashioned smackdown Roman reigns and
Dwayne teaming up as a sort of tag-team
against a couple of mercenaries is
pretty awesome it's going to be a huge
treat for wrestling fans bringing a new
villainous dimension to the Fast and
Furious franchise and adding to the
already stellar roster of actors in
series is Idris Elba as brixton the
self-proclaimed black Superman looks to
be one of the most powerful foes Hobbs
and Shaw have encountered thus far
described in the official plot
description as a cyber genetically
enhanced anarchist brixton is a
supervillain who appears to be abusing
technology to make himself harder bigger
faster stronger oh and it looks like
he's bulletproof to boot with trailers
for Hobson Shaw showing the villain
using technology to bulk up and Hulk out
while also threatening the world with an
insidious bio threats
rickston promises to be a next level
heavy asked by Collider whether he
wanted to build a whole new world of
characters for Hobbes and Shaw or borrow
some familiar faces from the franchise
leech sounds like he's open to the idea
of cameos I think it'd be fun to nod and
have a couple of the characters come by
and you know sort of make their
appearances we have a really strong
point of view that we want to create our
own characters for this world that
certainly sounds like the answer of a
man holding his cards close to the vest
as he should be
surprise cameos of this nature always
work best when they're at their most
unexpected still we perhaps shouldn't
rule out a brief surprise appearance
from beloved characters like Ludacris's
tej Parker or Tyrese Gibson Roman Pearce
however the greatest and most unexpected
cameo may come from someone outside the
existing fast family Keanu Reeves was
rumored to make an appearance in the
film but unfortunately the rock himself
shot down that much-anticipated cameo in
a conversation with MTV News saying I
will confirm that he's not in it by the
way that rumor just started to kind of
swell but I will tell you this we do
have some surprises coming just what
those surprises could be as anyone's
guess go to be the return upon a
surprise casting for a shawl patriarch
or could the rock just be blowing a
smoke screen to make the Keano cameo hit
even harder don't get your hopes up for
a cameo appearance from Vin Diesel and
Hopson shawl though not even at the
traditional post action barbeque not
only is Hobson Shaw looking to establish
it's own cinematic universe without
Toretto but there's still the alleged
beef between diesel and Johnson to deal
with that beef surfaced in August 2016
during the last week of filming fate of
the Furious when Johnson published a
cryptic Instagram post which implied
that an anonymous co-star wasn't
conducting himself as a quote true
professional and that fans could see his
blood quotes legit boiling in some
scenes the viewed seemed to drag on for
months under the guise of vague social
media back-and-forth with Michelle
Rodriguez even confirming it to people
the bros man their friends and
ultimately even friends reach a point
where they have to set aside their
differences to make a movie for
multicultural people around the world
and that is the bigger scheme of things
the two have since reportedly buried the
hatchet with Johnson telling
Entertainment Tonight that he and diesel
are simply different people just like in
life you have different philosophies and
people have different fundamental
philosophies on how you do things
meanwhile diesel said of his co-star we
still love each other
that's my boy The Fast & Furious
franchise has built a reputation for
itself as one of the boldest most
ridiculous and bombastic action film
series ever made with leech directing
Hobson Shaw and regular fast and furious
writer Chris Morgan behind the
screenplay
the spin-off looks as though it's in
capable hands for maintaining that
reputation not only did Morgan pen the
first film he's also the man behind the
genius resurgence of the franchise from
Fast Five onwards he's the writer who
looked at the ludicrously giant action
sequences already delivered by the
franchise and said no let's go bigger
starts out stealing DVD players in East
LA ends up heisting a hundred million
dollars in Rio meanwhile leech might be
one of Hollywood's most highly
sought-after and respected action
directors the former stuntman directed
atomic blonde and Deadpool 2 and
co-directed the first John wick he's the
perfect director to bring into the
franchise at this moment and he's sure
to put his own frenetic sardonic spin on
the series with Hobbes and Shaw as
you're probably well aware from having
watched and re-watched the trailers for
Hobbes and Shaw with your mouth swinging
open at all
we've already seen a lot of action but
for those afraid that the promo clips
have given away the movies best set
pieces Chris Morgan is here to set those
fears at ease
telling Empire that there's more to come
we have so much that we're holding back
this is a blink of the action in the
Apple Inc it's a gutsy claim to make but
a believable one after all if you
compare the trailers that were released
for fate of the Furious with the actual
film it's easy to see how the promos
barely scratched the surface with so
much action and story to tell there's
also a fair chance that Hobbs and Shaw
could share a similar running time to
pay to the pyrius which gave audiences
an epic one hundred and fifty minute
cinematic ride if you're giddy at the
prospect of Hobbs and Shaw enjoying
their own series of films rather than
just one standalone spin-off you're in
luck
leach has confirmed that Hobbs and Shaw
is intended as the first movie of an
ongoing franchise the director told
Collider we're starting a franchise so
we want it to be a little bit more
grounded it's a little bit more
character centric we're going to set up
the stakes for these guys in their
relationship if that sounds a little
slow for a fast and furious movie you've
got nothing to worry about
we're also gonna have some you know
great set pieces and so you know action
that you'd expect and in that type of
franchise you know it's something that
opens in summer awesome though that
maybe there is a downside it means that
Hobbs and Shaw probably won't be
starring in Fast and Furious 9 while
their own respective franchise gets
going the long-running Fast and Furious
franchise could be coming to an end
after the next couple of films but it
seems as though the sagas creative team
is already putting plans in place to
keep the series alive in new and
exciting ways Hobbs and Shaw is the
first of many planned Fast and Furious
spin-offs on top of a theme park ride
diesel has also teased that a Fast and
Furious movie with a woman in the lead
may be coming soon and an Instagram
posts shared at the beginning of 2019
diesel revealed that he and producer
Samantha Vincent had heard a pitch at
Universal for just such a movie judging
by his Instagram caption it sounds like
it went well there are three new
spin-offs that we have promised
Universal this week we heard a pitch for
the fast female protagonist driven
spin-off by creative in 2017 and you can
tell by the smile on Samantha's face it
was very exciting in the meantime we'll
just have to live like da I live my life
a quarter mile at a time check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the fast
and furious are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]